bueno si bien este hecho no fue
reivindicado como decíamos por el grupo
talibán los insurgentes están avanzando
como también decíamos sobre más
territorio no y esto mientras se
concrete al retiro de las tropas
estadounidenses y de otros países no de
afganistán y ahora es el propio eeuu no
quien dice temer por el riesgo de una
guerra civil que le espera a afganistán
que podemos esperar
bueno así es santiago efectivamente los
talibán nunca se fueron en estas dos
largas décadas de ocupación militar no
sólo de eeuu y no de tropas una
coalición de fuerzas también en las que
estaban las tropas de la otan
encontramos que realmente hay una deriva
sobre todo hacia la violencia y el
riesgo de una guerra civil es muy cierto
hay que recordar santiago que afganistán
no es un país como se dice en la prensa
occidental sino que es una sumatoria de
tribus de etnias y de religiosidad es
varias con lo cual los talibán
simplemente se replegaron a las montañas
y ahora están volviendo a tomar el
control de muchas provincias con lo cual
van a disputarle el poder político
afgana el presidente que solamente
gobierna en kabul y los alrededores de
la capital afgana
ahora susana pasaron 20 años de guerra
no pudieron desarticular o restarle
poderío al grupo talibán en todo ese
tiempo y que tanto podrán resistir las
fuerzas afganas una vez que se concrete
el retiro de las tropas extranjeras
esa es la gran incógnita que han hecho
las tropas estadounidenses pero también
otros aliados con los que eeuu la propia
españa envió tropas allí también como
otros países europeos han sido 20 años
de ocupación militar en toda regla han
perdido la guerra por más que me hayan
perdido el mismo número de soldados
norteamericanos que de afganos ha muerto
más de 70 mil afganos 26 mil 26 mil
niños perdón que han sido mutilados y
asesinados
lo que ocurre es que ha sido muy difícil
luchar contra los señores de la guerra
porque son los mismos que después
proporcionan trabajo a los campesinos
afganos afganistán eso y santiago la
fábrica de opio y de heroína de muchos
mercados salvo el estadounidense que se
nutre de la droga que viene de
latinoamérica el resto de los mercados
depende de ese opio que se produce se
cultiva y se fabrica hoy en
ganis tan con lo cual los talibán lo que
hacen es cobrar peaje y cobrar impuestos
pero también dan trabajo a millones de
afganos con lo cual ha sido muy difícil
combatir esto en estos 20 años